liking ourselves having high self esteem
as we tend to put it is crucial to any
feeling of well-being what's odd then is
just how unpredictable the allocation of
esteem often turns out to be there are
people with modest jobs unspectacular
bodies and unglamorous friends
confidently nevertheless lay claim to
buoyant levels of self esteem they seem
to like themselves despite the absence
of any vigorous signs of approval from
the world at large and then there are
others for whom no amount of achievement
prestige and financial security ever
seems to do the trick they anxiously
chastise and critique themselves always
feeling that they've underperformed
never quite trusting that they really
deserve to exist having sound levels of
self esteem ultimately appears to have
precious little to do with hitting any
verifiable benchmarks it seems connected
up with a stranger more internal more
subjective kind of logic with factors
immune to standard notions of
achievement three factors stand out in
particular firstly what your same-sex
parent did the single greatest
determinant of how much you will esteem
yourself is how you compare with your
same-sex parent whether you've achieved
more or less than mum or dad rather
brutally it seems that comfortable
levels of self-esteem are only available
to those who've managed to outpace their
same-sex parent those from a poor
background have a big unwitting
advantage you might only be driving a
beaten-up old taxi around Manhattan and
living in one room in Harlem but if your
same-sex parent was a subsistence farmer
from Eastern Burkina Faso you will at
times feel princely nevertheless
similarly yet more darkly you might have
grown up in ostensibly privileged
circumstances but if your same-sex
parent made a few hundred million and
you're only managing to pull in a
middle-class salary you're liable never
quite to shake off the haunting feeling
that you're a disgrace
secondly what your peer group is up to
we don't feel inadequate in relation to
everyone who has more than us only those
we've come to see is belonging to
another crucial determinant a
self-esteem or peer group by this we
mean the people who were educated with
us who are around our age and who live
in our part of the world these people
matter infinitely more to our sense of
well-being than the population at large
it's a piece of extreme bad luck and a
matter for particular commiseration and
assistance if ever our peer group
produces someone who starts a
billion-dollar company or god forbid
ends up running the country every time
someone we went to school with does
better than us a small part of us will
die we should therefore take immense
care to attend very ordinary schools and
after graduation to throw all
invitations to reunions straight in the
trash thirdly what kind of love you
received in childhood a lot depends on
what kind of affection we were the
recipients of in childhood in particular
how many conditions our love came
attached with some of us had parents who
only knew how to give out the
conditional kind of love it was all
about the grades and the school reports
we therefore grew up of course to be
high achievers but it's not so easy
running around your whole life long
desperate to put out the raging fires of
self-hatred striving to impress everyone
you meet in search of an unsatisfied
desire for a parental approval you never
knew but others the blessed ones who've
known unconditional love from the start
will be okay just to be they won't have
to do quite so much pushing the had an
inner basic buoyancy guaranteed by the
knowledge that they once mattered
immeasurably a big reversal like being
fired will be unpleasant it won't
necessarily have to be a tragedy
knowing about the odd internal origins
of self-esteem is crucial because of how
often we pursue goals in the belief that
success will at last give us the keys to
feeling good about ourselves
it seems the truth is slightly darker
you might ostensibly be doing very well
at work but if your dad was a big shot
or your school buddy became president or
your parents didn't tank you up with the
right unconditional sort of love no
amount of striving goal scoring and
medal winning is ever really gonna do it
this change is where we should imagine
our challenges lie feeling good about
ourselves isn't ultimately something we
can bring about through professional or
economic achievements alone in huge part
it's going to be about coming to terms
with ourselves the result of
understanding our past and the dynamics
of shame conditionality and humiliation
that might lie there it turns out that
high self-esteem seems largely to be a
prize of psychology rather than the
fruit of anything we might achieve out
in the world in relation to the economy
you